first before we move on to some of the
day's news I just wanted to react to
what you saw there in Becky Johnson's
report the pressures on ambulance
services in Becky's report and all
across the country
painted of what's happening in Coventry
I recognized absolutely from my own
constituency in Wigan and I think most
people will in every part of the country
now it is completely unsustainable the
pressure that the government is piling
on to our Health Service particularly
the a e which is the warning light that
flashes on the dashboard when the system
isn't working it's clear to everybody
that we've got to get more people
working in our National Health Service
we've got to increase the capacity of
the staff who are burnt out and
exhausted we've got to reform GP
Services primary care services so that
fewer people are going into our anes and
we've got to really start to get a grip
hopefully a cross-party grip on social
care in order to get more people out and
home and into the community where they
can recover the government has set their
face against that this week they've said
that they universities have to cap the
number of medical school places we think
that's unconscionable at a time when
most Health Trust are dealing with this
sort of Crisis yeah and you say they're
increasing staff and the other points
you made but no mention they're
increasing money would a labor
government increase the amount of money
going into the Health Service
and non-dom tax status and increase the
number of people coming into the
National Health Service the biggest
expansion in Workforce in recent decades
we think that's a significant
contribution to helping the ease the
pressures in the National Health Service
and we've been Unapologetic about the
fact that the NHS has been for a long
time our Crown Jewel but it's not
working and it needs reform and
particularly the parts that need reform
are the front door of the National
Health Service the numbers of people
coming through into our hospitals
because they can't get treatment
elsewhere and the back door as well the
number of people who are stuck in
hospital because they can't get out
that non-dome status reform is going to
be a couple of billion pounds isn't it I
mean would a labor government increase
taxes to help fund the NHS and social
care
we don't think there's
people in this country can pay more
taxes at the moment the tax burden is at
the highest rate for decades people are
struggling with the cost of living
crisis the Tories crashed the economy
inflation has gone through the roof the
idea that you would raise taxes on
people at this stage is for the birds
but what you can do is make fairer
choices and we've tried to set that out
so far through our non-dom tax status
funding and expansion of the NHS
Workforce and through taxes like the
windfall tax to get money back into
people's pockets one of the things that
I was told in my local hospital last
week is that some of the people who
they're struggling to discharge who are
medically fit to go home but need more
care it's not just a lack of social care
it's the fact that they're going home to
cold homes without food in the cupboards
that's just unbelievable in this country
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world in the 21st century and we've got
to start dealing with the wider crisis
that exists and relieve the pressure on
the National Health Service okay at
least just away from the Health Service
then but it's all about those kind of
choices that can be made you'll know the
convention of the north of course has
taken place all right now what would a
labor government do to make sure that a
place is like your constituency placed
in the north of England get more funding
free problem that we've got whether it's
the crisis in funding our Public
Services whether it's the energy
Revolution that we're living through
trying to transition from fossil fuels
to clean energy all of the problems that
Britain faces come down to one thing
we've had very low sluggish economic
growth over the last decade because
we've written off the assets and
potential in most parts of the country
I'm going to tell the convention today
that we can't go on like this that our
political system has to change or die we
can't continue with this absurd system
where ministers sit behind desks in
Whitehall and hand little bits of our
money back to us in the north of England
for traffic light improvements and
picnic areas to be expanded we need to
get serious about growing every part of
our economy hydrogen in Ellesmere Port
wind in Grimsby there is huge potential
across this country to get every part of
the country able to make a con their
full contribution again instead for too
long this government has written people
off and written them out of the national
story because of where they live and we
believe that that's got to change
so I mean you've called the leveling up
a bidding process like The Hunger Games
I mean would the labor government have
set amounts for each region that they
could then draw on as if they were
government departments
well we believe that there needs to be
far more flexibility in the budgets that
was the Mayors already have
it's absurd that you've got a system at
the moment where they're having to go
and bid to dozens of different
government departments to drive growth
and build resilient local economies it
just doesn't work I mean to give you one
of the most absurd examples if you want
money for buses you have to go to one
Department if you want money for bus
charging points you have to go to
another we don't think you should reform
that system we think you should end that
system and put power and resources into
local hands in those communities so that
they can drive growth and align National
budgets behind them we think we can be
far more ambitious and today what you'll
hear from a thousand business Civic and
political leaders Gathering across the
north is a speaking with one voice to
say we need a government that matches
our ambition
at least 90 finally while I do have you
I do want to ask you a question about
something that happened last week in
Parliament um you would have seen the
exchanges uh involving uh Rosie Duffield
and Lloyd royal Russell Moyle I mean did
you witness that and what did you think
of of what you saw in Parliament
I've seen the clip
literally this is a debate that needs
far more light and far less heat and I
think it's extraordinary that you've got
people labor labor members of parliament
um this time shouting each other down
when this is a debate that has a lot of
nuance in it and people need to be heard
there's a lot of concern out in the
country about it and we need to calm
down we need to remember that the people
that we're talking about are human
beings and we need to have a far more
respectful and far more decent debate
and I would say that to all of my
colleagues yeah I'm sure that everyone
would agree that it needs to calm down
somewhat do you think an apology is due
from a Mr Russell Moyle to Rosie
Duffield
but look I wasn't there I know what I
saw on the clips and I think if if Rosie
was being shouted at which it certainly
looked like she was then yeah of course
I think you should apologize for
shouting at other members of parliament
in uh in uh you know in a debate but you
know like I said I've only seen the clip
so I don't know what else was going on
in there I I think that's a definitely a
matter for the speaker I think he takes
very seriously the fact that we've got
to show the best of the political system
to the country and that day clearly we
didn't but I do think there's a wider
Point here as well when I I look at the
way that this debate is conducted
particularly in relation to trans people
I think when we look back in history
we'll be thoroughly ashamed of the way
that we allowed this to be reduced to
um questions of people's body parts when
we're talking about human beings and
some of the more hysterical
um arguments that are being propagated
particularly on social media I don't
think Rosie Duffield was doing that I
think she was contributing to the debate
I think she deserved to be heard I think
all people who contribute to that debate
deserve to be heard but I think it's a
symbol of where we've got to in this
country with this debate that we've
we've lost the ability to listen to one
another to understand one another and in
the end it's not politicians who suffer
for that it's some of the most
marginalized discriminated against
people in the country
okay listen Andy appreciate your time
this morning listen under your Shadow
leveling up secretary thank you